This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一档I-Heart播客节目。百分之二。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身以及建立适应力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历考验后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《2%》。名字就是两个百分号。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他将罪有应得。我们常说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。欢迎收听《回首当年》播客。对于1979年来说，对我而言那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说也很重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《回首当年》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《知难而进》。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都不太安全进行的坦诚对话，而你是在与一位懂行的持证专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《知难而进》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces
在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦女士，你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试结果，对吗？我篡改过一次测试结果。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临
consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. Before we get into things, this episode does deal with discussions of abuse, please just take a moment to assess whether that is something that you are ready to hear today. This episode will still be here tomorrow. It will still be here in a week, in a few months,
后果。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《受困之爱》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你的二十岁心理学》，这是一个探讨我们二十岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落，很高兴你能来到这里收听又一期节目，当然，我们将在节目中剖析二十岁的心理学。在进入正题之前，本集节目确实涉及关于虐待的讨论，请花一点时间评估一下这是否是你今天准备好听的内容。这集节目明天依然会在这里。一周后，几个月后，它也依然会在这里，
when you are in a better headspace to perhaps return to it. So it is your decision, but just giving you a heads up and a reminder to please take care of yourself. A really hot topic in the dating realm in the dating world at the moment is love bombing. And it has been for a while now. You see TikToks and reels of it everywhere, articles about how to tell if he's love bumming you. You hear horror stories from people who think that they have found the one and discover, you know, three months later that it was all a manipulation strategy,
当你处于更好的心理状态时，或许可以再回来听。所以这是你的决定，但只是给你一个预告和提醒，请照顾好自己。目前约会领域、约会世界中一个非常热门的话题是“轰炸式示爱”。而且这种情况已经持续了一段时间。你到处都能看到关于它的TikTok和短视频，还有关于如何判断他是否在对你进行轰炸式示爱的文章。你会听到一些人的恐怖故事，他们以为自己找到了真爱，结果发现，你知道的，三个月后，这一切都只是一种操纵策略，
these grand gestures that leave us confused as to whether this person is truly infatuated with us or just likes the idea of you or is just trying to get something from you. It can all be a little bit confusing to distinguish between a true connection and love bombing, especially in this day and age when there is so much confusion and contradictory information about what actually constitutes a love bombing situation and when to be worried. It's something we see a lot, right? You know, when a term like love bombing enters our collective psychobabble, it can become quite twisted and sometimes misused and actually leave us with less answers
这些宏大的姿态让我们感到困惑，不知道这个人是真的迷恋我们，还是仅仅喜欢你的形象，或者只是想从你身上得到什么。要在真正的连接和轰炸式示爱之间区分开来，可能会有点令人困惑，尤其是在当今这个时代，关于究竟什么构成了轰炸式示爱情况以及什么时候该担忧，有这么多的困惑和矛盾的信息。这是我们经常看到的情况，对吧？你知道的，当像轰炸式示爱这样的词进入我们的集体心理流行语时，它可能会变得相当扭曲，有时甚至被滥用，实际上让我们在理解它们时得到的答案更少，
and less clarity in understanding them before. And the stakes are also really high, right? When it comes to love, everything takes on a whole new level of significance. Because love is such a soft and vulnerable part of us. And at the end of the day, it's kind of all that we want to be seen and cared for and adored and spoiled. We probably also know what it feels like to be hurt and disappointed, how hard it is to find a real connection amongst dozens of dead ends and duds. So when somebody comes along and seemingly offers us everything that we've ever wanted
得到的清晰度比以前更少。而且利害关系也非常重大，对吧？当谈到爱情时，一切都带有了全新层面的意义。因为爱情是我们内心如此柔软和脆弱的一部分。归根结底，这基本上就是我们所渴求的一切——被看见、被关爱、被宠爱、被纵容。我们可能也知道受伤和失望是什么滋味，知道在无数的死胡同和无用功中找到真正的连接是多么困难。所以当某人出现，看似提供了我们一直以来想要的一切，
and has no faults, we can fall pretty quickly. The hard part is discerning when that connection and all those brilliant acts of service and gifts and affirmations is derived from an organic place or when it is potentially a facade, a sign of something more sinister. that is to come, or maybe even a habit that this person has learned to kind of entice you in and then switch everything around when they have you. So let's talk about it today. What is the actual psychology behind love bombing? Where does this concept come from? What does it have in common with cults and Snapchat? What are some of the biggest signs and, of course, the distinction
而且毫无缺点时，我们很容易就会沦陷。困难的部分在于辨识，当这种连接以及所有那些精彩的服务举动、礼物和肯定来自于一个自然真诚的地方，还是它可能只是一种虚伪的面具，是未来更阴险的事情的征兆，或者甚至只是这个人学会的一种习惯，用来吸引你入彀，然后在把你搞到手后把一切都翻转过来。所以我们今天来聊聊这个。轰炸式示爱背后的真正心理学是什么？这个概念从何而来？它与邪教和Snapchat有什么共同点？一些最大的征兆是什么，当然，还有如何区分
between once again something real and something artificial. Love versus love bombing. And how can we actually tell? I also want to talk about what makes some of us more susceptible to these behaviours and why it is definitely not your fault that you and me and everyone seems to get very caught up in this whirlwind of romance. But also some of the questions to really help you discern and determine what's actually going on. Whether you can really trust this situation, you can really trust this person's
再次说明，什么是真实的，什么是虚假的。真爱与轰炸式示爱。我们究竟该如何分辨？我还想谈谈是什么让我们中的一些人更容易受到这些行为的影响，为什么你、我以及每个人似乎都非常容易陷入这场浪漫的旋风中，这绝对不是你的错。同时，还有一些问题能够真正帮助你辨别和确定究竟发生了什么。你是否真的能信任这种情境，是否真的能信任这个人的
actions or whether it's time to maybe get out. So all of that and more. We have so much to talk about. The psychology behind this is fascinating, at times overwhelming. Without further ado, let's get into it. We all have some concept of what it means to be love bombed. Flowers every day. I love yous after the first date, promises of marriage by date three. You know, huge extravagant gifts, meeting the family, wanting to spend every second with you, very much being swept off your feet with grand gestures, ego boosts, and like a high level of commitment from the beginning that you may have always wanted from somebody. The way I like to put it is that a relationship that contains love bombing
行为，还是说或许该抽身离开了。所以，所有这些以及更多内容。我们有太多要聊的了。这背后的心理学令人着迷，有时又让人应接不暇。废话不多说，我们切入正题吧。我们对被轰炸式示爱意味着什么都有一些概念。每天都有鲜花。第一次约会后就说“我爱你”，第三次约会就承诺结婚。你知道的，巨大的奢华礼物，见家长，想和你分分秒秒都在一起，用宏大的姿态、自我价值的提升，以及从一开始就表现出你在过去可能一直渴望从某人那里获得的极高承诺感，让你彻底神魂颠倒。我喜欢这样比喻，包含轰炸式示爱的关系
appears to be like a typical relationship timeline on steroids. And you know what? it probably feels incredibly nice. That is the whole purpose of love bombing, you know, is it's to induce feelings of closeness and passion and intimacy and affection as soon as possible. And it's only natural that when this happens, you know, all of those logical and rational centres of our brains are essentially overridden by the very powerful chemical reactions that are happening in the other parts of our brain.
看起来就像是开了兴奋剂的典型关系发展时间表。你知道吗？这种感觉可能好得难以置信。这正是轰炸式示爱的主要目的，你知道的，就是尽早诱发出亲密感、激情、亲热感和爱意。而很自然地，当这种情况发生时，你知道的，我们大脑中所有那些逻辑和理性的中心，基本上都被我们大脑中负责处理情感的其他区域所发生的高强度化学反应给压倒了。
that are responsible for processing emotion. These areas are being flooded with dopamine and serotonin in response to this other person's affection and admiration. It is a very biological process at its core when we really examine it deep down. We respond so positively to displays of love. We crave so deeply intimacy and affection that when it is given to us, it's like fireworks. It's like everything in our brain goes into over time. drive. But under that pleasant, sometimes even addictive feeling is often a sinister intention.
为了回应另一个人的爱意和崇拜，这些区域正被多巴胺和血清素淹没。当我们深入剖析时，其核心其实是一个非常生物学的过程。我们对爱的表达反应如此积极。我们如此深深地渴望亲密和爱意，以至于当它给予我们时，就像是烟花绽放。就像我们大脑中的一切都进入了超负荷运转。但在那种令人愉悦、有时甚至让人上瘾的感觉之下，往往隐藏着一种阴险的意图。
Love bombing is at the end of the day an attempt to influence a person through demonstrations of attention and affection that will lower our defences and our ability to detect red flags, but also attach and bond us very quickly to that person who is displaying these behaviors. There is a benefit for them that we are perhaps not seeing. We are blinded by their extreme kindness and love. And that benefit may be to soothe their own insecurities and abandonment issues. It may be to create a power dynamic that means we will never leave them and they'll have all the control. It may be to create dependence, to control and manipulate, or to just, they get the exciting feelings from those early days. That's what they really want. And then when they're bored,
归根结底，轰炸式示爱是一种试图通过关注和爱意的展示来影响一个人的行为，这会降低我们的防御能力以及我们察觉危险信号的能力，同时也会使我们非常快速地依恋和绑定在那个表现出这些行为的人身上。对他们来说有一个好处，而我们可能没有看到。我们被他们极端的善良和爱蒙蔽了双眼。而这个好处可能是为了安抚他们自己的不安全感和被抛弃问题。可能是为了营造一种权力动态，这意味着我们永远不会离开他们，而他们将掌控一切。可能是为了制造依赖性、控制和操纵，或者只是为了从那些早期日子里获得令人兴奋的感觉。这才是他们真正想要的。然后当他们腻了，
they leave. The sinister or ulterior intentions, motivations of love. love bumming, that is a core characteristic of this behavior. You cannot have love bumming without that second component. And we can see that by really diving into the history of where the term has come from. So this behavior first got its name from a series of cults, including the Unification Church of the United States and the People's Temple, which you might know as the cult responsible for the Jonestown Massacre, and also another famous cult called the Branch Davidians, which was responsible for the Waco siege. So, you know, a very dark history. And the reason that this term was created was because these cults quickly discovered that excessive positive
他们就会离开。轰炸式示爱的阴险或不可告人的意图与动机，这是这种行为的核心特征。没有第二个组成部分，你就不能称之为轰炸式示爱。我们可以通过深入探究这个词的起源历史来看到这一点。所以，这种行为最初是从一系列邪教中得名的，包括美国的统一教会和人民圣殿教（你可能知道它是制造了琼斯镇惨案的邪教），以及另一个名为大卫教派的著名邪教，该邪教制造了韦科惨案。所以，你知道的，这是一段非常黑暗的历史。这个词之所以被创造出来，是因为这些邪教很快发现，过度的积极强化、过度的友谊和亲情展示、礼物和激励，
reinforcement, excessive displays of friendship and kinship, gifts and incentives, they were a really great way to get new members and to prevent them from leaving. This was one of their tactics for winning people over and building trust but also dependency and allegiance on a very short timeline. And as awful as it was, for their purpose it was very smart. They took one of our core needs, love and belonging, which sits only above our biological needs for food and water and our safety needs for security, and they artificially manipulated it to achieve what they wanted, which was total psychological control. If it could be used in those circumstances, and it definitely is, it can also be used in everyday and one-on-one relationships like in dating or even in friendship.
是吸引新成员以及防止他们离开的绝佳方式。这是他们赢得人心并建立信任的策略之一，同时也在很短的时间内建立起依赖性和效忠。尽管这很可怕，但为了他们的目的，这非常聪明。他们拿走了我们核心需求之一——爱与归属感（它仅排在我们对食物和水的生理需求以及对安全感的需求之上），并对其进行人工操纵以实现他们想要的东西，那就是完全的心理控制。如果它能在那种情况下被使用（而且它确实被使用了），它也可以在日常和一对一的关系中使用，比如在约会甚至友情中。
It's not like they were the first people to discover this, but they were the first to really use it for very extreme, large, sinister campaigns to win people over. Here is the thing that a lot of us don't realize though, but what we typically see as love bombing, the extravagance, the excitement, that is really only the first stage. So according to the psychiatrist Dale Archer, who did a lot of his initial research in his career on love bombing, he talked to patients, he heard about their experiences, love bombing actually tends to occur in three phases. So the idealization phase comes first. That is what we typically see is love bombing. Your partner really bombards you with excessive affection to draw you in,
并不是说他们是第一个发现这一点的人，但他们是第一个真正将其用于极其极端的、大规模的、阴险的运动来赢得人心的人。不过，很多我们没有意识到的一点是，我们通常认为的轰炸式示爱——那些铺张的奢华、兴奋，其实仅仅是第一阶段。因此，根据精神病学家戴尔·阿尔彻（Dale Archer）的说法，他在其职业生涯的早期研究中做了大量关于轰炸式示爱的研究，他采访了患者，听取了他们的经历，轰炸式示爱实际上往往分为三个阶段。理想化阶段首先出现。这就是我们通常认为的轰炸式示爱。你的伴侣确实用过度的爱意轰炸你，以吸引你入彀，
to let your guard down. You know, I've already mentioned a few signs of this, but some others that therapists often speak of include, you know, your partner rushes into locking things down. They're really jealous of your family and friends. They show up even when they weren't invited. They like you better when you're alone. They overcommuting. their love to the point where it may even make you feel uncomfortable. And at first it may seem too good to be true or too easy. And that is the purpose. That is what we want. That is what they want because what comes after that is the devaluation phase. And this is where we can really categorize their behavior
让你放下戒备。你知道的，我已经提到了一些这方面的征兆，但治疗师经常谈到的其他一些征兆包括，你知道的，你的伴侣急于把关系定下来。他们对你的家人和朋友非常嫉妒。即使没有被邀请，他们也会出现。他们更喜欢你独自一人。他们过度表达他们的爱，甚至到了可能会让你感到不舒服的地步。起初，这可能看起来好得令人难以置信，或者太容易了。而这正是目的。这正是我们想要的，这也是他们想要的，因为随之而来的是贬低阶段。正是在这里，我们才能真正将他们的行为归类为
as love bumming. When it feels like the honeymoon period kind of suddenly bursts overnight. Once you start to let your guard down and get comfortable in this relationship, the red flags start to peer because they've won your trust. They may try to exert control over you in a variety of ways, being very demanding of your time, being very upset when you make plans without them, they might limit your access to your friends and family, they may start fights just to kind of exert control over you and to stop you from going to events. You know, a lot of emotional manipulation, a lot of gaslighting. The gifts, you know, they become less regular. The compliments are also mixed in with insults, but we keep thinking back to those early days and expecting this past version of them
轰炸式示爱。当蜜月期仿佛在一夜之间突然破裂的时候。一旦你开始放下戒备，在这段关系中感到舒适，危险信号就开始出现，因为他们已经赢得了你的信任。他们可能会试图以各种方式对你施加控制，对你的时间要求极高，当你没有他们而做出计划时会非常沮丧，他们可能会限制你接触朋友和家人的机会，他们甚至可能为了施加控制并阻止你参加活动而挑起争端。你知道的，大量的精神操纵，大量的情感虐待（Gaslighting）。那些礼物，你知道的，变得不那么规律了。赞美中也夹杂着侮辱，但我们一直回想起那些早期日子，并期待着他们的这个过去版本
and this past version of our love to come back because of how deeply rewired the idealization phase has made us. In really severe cases, we don't just see psychological manipulation and emotional abuse, but also physical abuse. And when you confront them, what you enter in that moment is the third stage. And the third stage is the discard phase. When you try and work things through with them, when you instigate meaningful conversation, when you attempt to reset healthy boundaries, this person your partner may avoid accountability by refusing to cooperate, refusing to talk about it, refusing to compromise, or by abandoning the relationship altogether. And this can leave you feeling really confused and really disorientated because, you know, a couple weeks ago, it was like
以及我们爱情的过去版本能够回来，因为理想化阶段对我们的重塑是如此深刻。在非常严重的情况下，我们看到的不仅是心理操纵和情感虐待，还有身体虐待。当你与他们对质时，你那一刻进入的是第三阶段。第三阶段就是丢弃阶段。当你试图与他们把事情理清，当你挑起有意义的对话，当你试图重置健康的界限时，这个人——你的伴侣——可能会通过拒绝承担责任来逃避，拒绝配合，拒绝谈论此事，拒绝妥协，或者干脆彻底放弃这段关系。这会让你感到非常困惑和迷失方向，因为，你知道的，几周前，这还像是
the most brilliant, beautiful TV romance of the century, and now here you are, alone. There's also, you know, likely to be some level of dependence and emotional reliance, which means that we've been so, like, hyped up by these huge feelings and emotions that we can't help but kind of feel compelled to go back and to try and win them over and to try and see what went wrong and we really want the relationship to work. And that is when the love bumming cycle typically begins again. This person attempts to repair the bond or repair the wound that they have left by doing what they know works, which is all of those extreme examples of love. This is important to note because, you know, this might sound controversial,
世纪中最灿烂、最美丽的电视浪漫剧，而现在你却孤身一人。此外，你知道的，还可能会有某种程度的依赖和情感依恋，这意味着我们被这些巨大的感觉和情绪搞得如此亢奋，以至于我们忍不住感到被迫回去，试图赢得他们的欢心，试图找出究竟哪里出了问题，我们真的很想让这段关系维系下去。而这通常就是轰炸式示爱循环再次开始的时候。这个人试图通过做他们知道有效的事情来修复纽带或修复他们留下的伤口，那就是所有那些极端的示爱行为。这一点很重要，因为，你知道的，这听起来可能很有争议，
but the behaviours we typically associate with love bombing, those things that we see in the first stage, are, in themselves and alone, they're not evil or manipulative. Actually, they're pretty special, you know, it's not all that impossible that someone may actually fall head over heels with you, and it could be like a natural and an intense reaction. It's not like you cannot accept flowers because it's love bobbing. Somebody might say, I love you a little bit too,
但我们通常与轰炸式示爱相关的行为——我们在第一阶段看到的那些事情——本身以及单独来看，并不是邪恶的或操纵性的。事实上，它们挺特别的，你知道的，某人确实可能会为你神魂颠倒，这并非完全不可能，而且这可能是一种自然而强烈反应。并不是说你不能接受鲜花，因为那就是轰炸式示爱。有人可能会说“我爱你”说得有点太早了，你知道的，因为他们，这只是人之常情。有些人确实会动真情，并且完全没有操纵你的意图。但随之而来的是什么，这才是关键。第二阶段和第三阶段才真正创造了轰炸式示爱的循环和局面。正如我刚才所提到的，你知道的，轰炸式示爱也可以成为虐待循环的一部分，
soon, you know, because they're, it's just human. Some people just really do get in their feelings and have no intention of manipulating you. But it's what comes after that. It's phase two and phase three that really create the love bombing cycle and situation. As I've already mentioned, you know, love bombing can become also a part of a cycle of abuse whereby it's not just that they use these, you know, activities and behaviors to entice you, but they use them to control you and they use them as a way of reconciling with you after arguments, after incidences of abuse. So there was this really amazing article about this by a women's aid group, which I'll put in the description. And in that article, this is what they had to say. Love bombing becomes
不仅是因为他们使用这些活动和行为来吸引你，还因为他们用这些来控制你，并将其作为在争吵、虐待事件发生后与你和解的一种方式。所以，妇女援助组织（Women's Aid）有一篇关于此的非常棒的文章，我会把它放在简介里。在那篇文章中，他们是这样说的：轰炸式示爱成为了施虐者对伴侣施加强制控制的一种有效工具，因为它的目的是让你在一切都变糟时仍然抱有希望，正是这种希望，你知道的，有时会导致人们选择留下。所以我们继续。我们来谈谈为什么人们会进行轰炸式示爱。他们的大脑里发生了什么？这里的需求是什么？这里有一个我们还没有谈到的概念，当我们讨论轰炸式示爱时，它真的需要被提出来。谈论轰炸式示爱，就不能不谈论自恋。简单回顾一下，自恋基本上描述了一系列以极端自我参与和自我重要感为核心的人格特质。
an effective tool to abusers as they exert coercive control over a partner because it is intended to keep you still hopeful even when it all goes bad and it's that hope that, you know, causes people to sometimes stay. So let's move on. Let's talk about why it is that people love bomb. What's going on in their brains? What's the need here? There is a concept here that we haven't spoken about yet that really needs to be brought up when we're having conversations about lovebombing. You cannot talk about love bombing without also talking about narcissism. Narcissism for a quick catch-up describes basically a network of personality traits that centre around an extreme sense of self-involvement and self-importance.
表现出自恋特质或患有人格障碍的人全神贯注于他们自己的利益和需求，即使这些是以牺牲他人为代价的。他们从你这里唯一想要的就是你能给他们的东西。他们想要你的关注，他们想要你的赞美，他们想要——一切都是为了他们。这基本上就是自恋。这个人只专注于他们从某种情境中试图获得什么。
A person displaying narcissistic traits or who has narcissistic personality disorder is preoccupied by their own interests and needs, even if they are at the expense of somebody else. The only thing they want from you is what you can give them. They want your attention, they want your admiration, they want, everything is for them. That's basically what narcissism is. The person is only focused on what they seek to gain from a situation.
所以我想这不会让人感到意外，自恋、人格特质与轰炸式示爱之间存在着显着的关联。在2017年发表的一项非常迷人的研究中，研究人员观察了近500名大学生的个性、关系形成，他们发现轰炸式示爱被用作建立关系的一种方式，尤其且专门在那些报告了以下情况的个体中：A，低自尊；B，不安全型依恋；C，自恋人格特质。这非常合乎逻辑，因为正如一位研究人员所说，
So I don't think that it will come as a surprise that there is a significant correlation between narcissism, personality traits and love bombing. In a really fascinating study published in 2017, researchers observed almost 500 college students, their personalities, their relationship formation, and they found that love bombing was used as a way to form relationships, especially and specifically amongst individuals who reported A, low self-esteem, B, an insecure attachment, and C, narcissistic personality traits. This makes a lot of sense because, as one researcher put it, the psychological reasoning behind
轰炸式示爱背后的心理推理是：我需要让你信任我。我需要你只想要我而不是别人。我想讨好你。我想建立你的信任，这样当我以后抛弃你时，你不会知道灾难何时降临，而我永远不会成为那个感到被抛弃或拒绝的人。我总是能够成为掌控一切的人，因为这样我才能永远满足自己的需求。通过用正向强化压倒某人，轰炸式示爱者制造了一种依赖感，而接受者可能会觉得自己再也找不到如此强烈的爱意
love bombing is, I need to get you to trust me. I need you to only want me and not somebody else. I want to get on your good side. I want to build your trust so that when I discard you later, you're not going to know what's coming and I will never be the one who feels abandoned or rejected. I always get to be the one who was in control because that way I am the one who always gets my needs met. By overwhelming somebody with positive reinforcement, the love bummer creates a sense of dependency and the recipient may feel that they could never find such an intense affection
和认可了。因此这使得你很难离开，甚至在关系变质时也是如此。轰炸式示爱是为了个人利益而进行的操纵，但这也是一种保护他们自我价值（自我）的方式。他们能够尽快并随心所欲地拥有你和你的爱。他们能够玩这场游戏。他们能够让你持续投入。然后当他们玩够了，他们就可以在自己想要的时候结束它。
and validation anywhere else. So it makes it very hard, makes it very difficult for you to want to leave, even when the relationship turns sour. Love bombing is manipulation for personal gain, but it's also a way to protect their ego. They get to have you and your affection as quickly and when they want it. They get to play the game. They get to keep you invested. And then when they're done, they get to end it when they want.
轰炸式示爱的根源是操纵，但也是控制和权力。推动这一现象的不仅仅是自恋，你知道的，混乱和不安全型依恋也发挥了作用。因此，我刚引用的那篇论文的作者也简短地提到了这一点，具有焦虑型依恋风格的人可能会发现自己会参与进某些看起来像轰炸式示爱的行为中，这并不总是为了控制的目的，而是因为一种与生俱来的不安全感和恐惧，这种恐惧导致他们加速关系的发展，担心如果给对方机会，对方就会离开。如果他们
The root of love bombing is manipulation, but it's also control and power. It's not just narcissism that drives this, you know, disorganize. and insecure attachment also plays a role. So the authors of that, same paper I just referenced, also mentioned it briefly, but people with an anxious attachment style may find themselves engaging in some
应用所有这些将某人绑定到自己身上的战术，如果他们用赞美、礼物和情感来冲刷对方，被拒绝或心碎的机会就会减少。这依然具有操纵性。它旨在影响局势，但出于完全不同的原因。这会让它变得更健康吗？绝对不会。因为它仍然涉及到营造一个虚假的幻境和人工的环境，让他们看起来像是绝配，直到他们开始对现状感到更好，直到他们感到安全，直到他们把你搞到手。所以这只是对为什么某人会煽动这种行为模式的另一种解释。最后一个解释，你知道的，还有相当多其他的解释，但这些是三大主要原因。我想提到的关于为什么人们会轰炸式示爱的最后一个解释，与我们可能称之为“强度成瘾”的东西有关。有些人就是喜欢蜜月期。这就是他们来这里的全部目的。
of the behaviours that look like love bombing and not always for the purposes of control, but because of an innate insecurity and fear that causes them to speed up the relationship out of a worry that the other person will leave if they are given the chance. If they
因此，他们只有一个短暂的窗口期来塞进所有的深厚情感、爱、狂喜、坠入爱河的美丽，然后当事情开始变得太严肃时，他们就可以撤离了。通过轰炸式示爱快速推进一段关系，让他们获得了他们想要的强烈高潮，而无需承担承诺。这是一个绝佳的方式，可以在永远不必经历低谷的情况下获得所有的巅峰体验，因为他们在蜜月期结束前的几个月就离开了，而且整个过程中他们都握有大部分的主动权。我愿意对这些人给予某种程度的宽容。通常他们根本不知道自己正在这样做。这是一种早已根植于他们内心深处的潜意识关系模式，也许是因为他们曾经受过伤，也许是因为他们对承诺过于害怕。而且通常这些感情在某种程度上是真实的。
apply, all of these tactics for bonding somebody to them, if they shower them in praise and gifts and feelings, there is less chance of rejection or heartbreak. It is still manipulative. It is intended to influence the situation, but for very different reasons. Does it make it healthier? Absolutely not. Because it does still involve creating a false environment and artificial circumstances that make them seem like the perfect match until they start to feel better about the situation, until they start to feel secure, until they have you. So it is just another explanation for why somebody might instigate this pattern of behaviours. A final explanation, you know, there are quite a few more, but these are the big
如果你让他们梳理关系的时间线，他们确实在乎他们约会过的人。但在他们的记忆中几乎存在某种空白，关于这段关系为什么会结束，因为承认这很可能是他们自己的问题，将意味着他们必须承认他们对时间线的加速实际上才是导致关系崩溃和烧毁的原因。
three. The final explanation I want to mention for why people love bomb has to do with what we might call intensity addiction. There are some people out there who just love the honeymoon phase. That's all they're here for. And so they have a brief window to squeeze in all the deep emotions. the love, the ecstasy, the beauty of falling in love, before things start to get too serious and then they can evacuate. Fast tracking a relationship through love bombing gives them the intense high that they want without the commitment. It is a great way to get all the highs without never having to experience the lows
而往往我们才是受害者，因为他们已经打卡下班了。一旦不再有趣，他们就立刻退出了这段关系。我认为由此我们可以多少确定一个轰炸式示爱的光谱或刻度。在一端，我们有自恋者以及那些刻意并精心策划自己想要拥有我们、控制我们、操纵我们的愿望的个体；而在另一端，我们有人群，他们的关系习惯和模式完全是混乱和粗心的。但问题是，在这个过程中受伤的依然是我们。
because they leave after only a few months before the honeymoon phase is over and the whole time they've had a lot of the power. I will give these individuals some level of grace. Often they have no idea that this is what they're doing. It is a subconscious relationship pattern that has been ingrained in them for a long time, maybe because they were once hurt, maybe because they just are too scared of commitment. And often the feelings are somewhat real.
问题在于：即使他们的动机并非出于恶意，即使感觉很美好，我们真的，我们想要的是一段持久的爱。这才是我们想要的。我们要的是健康、持久的爱，而不是即时满足，不是建立在兴奋和快节奏情绪基础上的短暂或人工的感觉。那终究会消退。有时很难分辨。我必须告诉你。当你可能花了相当大的一定时间去应付那些完全不给你任何东西或只给你最基本底线的人时，尤其难以分辨。你知道的，有时，某人的出现对我们大张旗鼓地追求，这是一种耳目一新的体验。而你也确实值得拥有这些。你值得拥有伟大而深沉的爱。关键在于区分什么时候这是真爱的征兆，什么时候是真正的连接，而什么时候是轰炸式示爱。所以这就是我们要谈的。接下来，什么是区别？我们如何辨别，以及在短暂休息之后我们如何保护自己？百分之二。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身以及建立适应力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员、其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历考验后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《2%》。名字就是两个百分号。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA上双击小肯姆（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么，乔治·布什跟小肯姆有什么关系？
And if you ask them for a relationship timeline, they do care about the people they dated. But there are these almost gap. in their memories around why the relationship ended, because acknowledging that perhaps it was most likely them would mean that they would have to recognize that their acceleration of the timeline was actually what caused it to crash and burn.
好吧，你可以在《回首当年》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期节目，马克·拉蒙特·希尔大谈80年代的快克可卡因。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备一整天都谈论快克，只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。
And it's often us that are the casualties, because they've already clocked out. They've already checked out of the relationship as soon as it wasn't fun anymore. I think from this we can kind of determine a little bit of a love-bombing spectrum or scale. At one end, we have narcissism and individuals who are deliberate and planned about their desire to have us to control us, to manipulate. And then we have people at the other end
所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了桌面上。谢谢你补充完那句话。是的。我认为对于黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。
whose relationship habits and patterns are just completely chaotic and careless. But the thing is, we are still the ones who get hurt in the process. And here's the thing. Even if their intentions aren't malicious, even when it feels good, we really, we want. want a love that lasts. That's what we want. We want a healthy, sustaining love, not one of instant gratification, not a temporary or artificial feeling that is built on the basis of exhilaration and fast-paced emotions. That will eventually fade. And it's hard to tell sometimes. Let me tell you that. It's especially hard to tell when you have maybe spent a good deal of time dealing with people who give you absolutely nothing, or the bare minimum. You know, sometimes it is it, it's a
请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《回首当年》。欢迎收听我的新播客《知难而进》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是：特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们追求某样东西时，
refreshing for somebody to come and come along and whine and dine us. And you do deserve that. You deserve great deep love. It's just about distinguishing between when that is a real sign of love, when that is a real connection versus love bombing. So that is what we're going to talk about. Next, what is the distinction? How can we tell and how can we protect ourselves after this short break? 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is a number of people who take the stairs when there also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical
我们太沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们总是盯着记分牌看。生活变成了关于赢和输。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，你觉得在这个世上当一个好人很重要吗？
and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. thinking, what the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill?
你当好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你只是真正地成为一个好人。加入我基尔·盖恩斯的行列，我们在我的新播客《知难而进》中就疗愈、成长、父职、压力和目标展开真实的对话。
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
打开你免费的iHeartRadio App。搜索《知难而进》并立即收听。在2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己陷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
埃伦女士，你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试结果，对吗？我篡改过一次测试结果。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的税款被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,
另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。
we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?
在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这还没完。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《受困之爱》播客。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。法则一，永远不要惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。法则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《闺蜜》的新一季中，
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway.
天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像是被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎。所以她们自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。
Open your free, Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself. at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
他将罪有应得。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。爱本该感觉美妙，你也本该被宠爱和善待。你确实值得拥有一个想要让你的生活变得更好、认为你很棒、给你送小礼物向你表明他们在想你并且能看到你们未来的伴侣。但这种健康的爱需要时间来沉淀。这是随着我年龄的增长、经历的感情越来越多、看到并观察到朋友们的感情越来越多，我越来越强烈地意识到的事情。
You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
那些慢慢建立起来的关系是建立在真实的情感之上的。而那些一夜之间突然出现的关系往往建立在冲动或某种人工的、短暂的事物之上。我认为有几个关键的关系特征可以用来区分轰炸式示爱与真爱。这些通常是节奏。轰炸式示爱涉及关系紧张而迅速的升级。轰炸式示爱者会在很早的时候就极力推动承诺和高度的亲密。你知道的，另一方面，真爱则需要时间，因为亲密感来自于经历、共同的记忆、价值观和成长
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
另外两个经历过同样事情的人，吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我简直震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends,
在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这件事还没完。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《陷入爱河》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，千万别惹乡下女孩。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。第二条规则，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《女朋友们》的新一季中，
Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target.
天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上。警察似乎并不在意。所以她们自己采取行动。我说，见鬼去吧。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。
He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Love is meant to feel amazing, and you are meant to be spoiled and treated well. you really do deserve someone who wants to make your life better and thinks that you are amazing and gives you little gifts showing you that they're thinking of you and sees a future with you. But the healthy version of this comes with time. It's something that I've definitely realized the older I've gotten, the more relationships I've been in, the more relationships I've seen my friends be in and I've observed.
他会得到他应得的。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《女朋友们：相信我，宝贝》。爱情应该感觉很美妙，你注定会被宠坏和善待。你真的值得拥有一个想要让你的生活更美好、认为你很棒、给你小礼物向你表明他们在想你并能看到与你的未来的人。但健康版本的爱情是需要时间积累的。这是我随着年龄增长、经历过更多感情、看到并观察到朋友们的更多感情后，绝对意识到的一点。
Those that are built slowly are built on real feeling. those that emerge overnight or often built on impulse or something artificial and short-lived. There are a few key relationship characteristics that I think distinguish or differ between love-bumbing and love. These are typically pacing. Love-bumbing involves an intense and rapid escalation of the relationship. The love-bumber will push very quickly for commitment and intense closeness very early on. You know, love, on the other hand, and takes time because closeness comes from experience and shared memories and values and growth
那些缓慢建立的感情是建立在真实情感之上的。而那些一夜之间出现的感情通常是建立在冲动或某种人工的、短暂的东西之上。我认为有几个关键的恋爱特征可以区分或区别于轰炸式示爱和真正的爱情。这些通常是节奏。轰炸式示爱涉及关系激烈而快速的升级。示爱者会非常迅速地推动在早期建立承诺和强烈的亲密感。你知道，另一方面，真正的爱情需要时间，因为亲密感来自于经历、共同的记忆、价值观和成长
as a partnership. The other component is inconsistency. Love should be consistent. Yes, you know, sometimes there are bumps in the road, but you know that the road is always going to be there and you know that the road will continue on. With love bumming, you might not know. Underneath the bright, brilliant feelings is often a twinge of anxiety and worry. Most people call that intuition, but we can confuse it with passion. Anxiety and excitement are very similar on a physical level. In both situations, our heart beats faster, our cortisol surges, our body is prepared for action, everything feels a bit tingly.
作为伙伴关系。另一个组成部分是不一致性。爱应该是稳定的。是的，你知道，生活中有时会有坎坷，但你知道路一直都在，而且你知道路会继续延伸。而爱的轰炸，你可能无法确定。在明亮、绚烂的感觉背后，往往隐藏着一丝焦虑和担忧。大多数人称之为直觉，但我们可能会把它和激情混淆。焦虑和兴奋在生理层面上非常相似。在这两种情况下，我们的心跳会加速，皮质醇会激增，身体会为行动做好准备，一切都会感觉有点麻刺。
It's how we interpret that emotion, our cognitions and our perceptions that determine what we see it as. It is very easy to ignore our gut feeling about a situation when it just feels. feels so sweet and good. But I think as the saying goes, if it feels too good to be true, maybe it is, and maybe it is valuable to interrogate the origin of that feeling. Another distinction, idealization and promises. Someone who has good intentions won't over-promise. They won't make commitments they can't keep, not just because they don't want to disappoint you, but also because they also want to be sure themselves. They don't want to get caught up.
正是我们对这种情感的解读、认知和感知，决定了我们如何看待它。当一种情况感觉如此甜蜜和美好时，我们很容易忽视内心的直觉。但我想就像那句老话说的，如果感觉好得不真实，那它可能就是假的，审视这种感觉的来源也许是有价值的。另一个区别是理想化和承诺。一个有好意的人不会过度承诺。他们不会做出无法兑现的承诺，不仅因为他们不想让你失望，还因为他们自己也想确信这一点。他们不想深陷其中。
that's really mature, and it shows respect and a natural level of caution. On the other hand, love bombers are not going to hold back. Marriage, next month, let's do it. Should we move in together? Yes, absolutely. Are you the love of my life? Yes, no doubts about it. We've only known each other for a week.
这真的很成熟，展现出了一种尊重和自然的谨慎。另一方面，情场骗子或爱的轰炸者是不会克制的。下个月结婚，我们办了吧。我们要同居吗？当然，绝对的。你是我的挚爱吗？是的，毫无疑问。我们才认识一个星期。
I still know. You get the picture. It's incredibly grandiose. And another factor in which these kind of relationship types, I don't know whether to call that, in which love and love bombing differ is, is power, is power, isolation, and control. It is my belief that healthy love isn't just sustained by what happens between you two, but also what you are allowed to pursue beyond the relationship.
我还是知道的。你懂的。这简直太宏大了。这类恋爱类型——我不知道该怎么称呼它——在爱与爱的轰炸中有所不同的另一个因素是，权力，权力、孤立和控制。我相信，健康的爱不仅靠你们两个人之间发生的事情来维持，也靠你们被允许在关系之外追求的事情来维持。
It's sustained by the things that exist outside of your kind of union. You have your own friends, you have your own interests in lives, but with love bombing, the relationship is all consuming. It is the center of your universe. If this is sounding very similar to codependency, that is because it is. There is this very similar concept when we talk about codependency called affection flooding. And I heard about this from a podcast called Relationships Made Easy, and the host talks about how affection flooding occurs when a codependent person
它靠存在于你们那种结合之外的事物来维持。你有你自己的朋友，你有你自己的生活兴趣，但在爱的轰炸中，这种关系是吞噬一切的。它是你宇宙的中心。如果这听起来很像共依赖，那是因为它确实是。当我们谈论共依赖时，有一个非常相似的概念叫做“情感泛滥”。我从一个名为《轻松搞定恋爱》的播客中听到了这个概念，主持人谈到了当一个共依赖的人时，情感泛滥是如何发生的
is engulfing their partner with an avalanche of affection and attention, driven by their deep-seated need for validation and external affirmation. It is very similar to love bombing, and the outcome in both situations is that you do become almost conjoined or attached to your partner. Everything becomes, you know, just them. All thoughts lead back to them. All actions or behaviour or choices lead back to them. I want to quickly stipulate.
用海啸般的情感和关注淹没他们的伴侣，这是由他们对认可和外部肯定的深层需求所驱动的。这与爱的轰炸非常相似，两种情况下的结果都是，你几乎与伴侣连体或依附在一起。一切都变成了，你知道，只有他们。所有的想法都指向他们。所有的行动、行为或选择都指向他们。我想快速说明一点。
I don't blame anybody who has ever been love-bombed and stayed, because it would be so hard to turn down, especially, as I said before, if you've gone through a number of situations or relationships in which all you ever wanted what, you know, was exactly what this person is now giving you. Commitment, excitement, generosity, love. It's even harder when our sense of self or our self-esteem has already been diminished by a previous situation that has just made us feel really understanding. undeserving or unlovable. This person, you know, when they come along and they have all these
我不怪任何曾被爱的轰炸过并留下来的人，因为拒绝真的太难了，尤其是正如我之前所说，如果你经历过许多情况或关系，而你一直想要的，你知道的，正是这个人现在给你的东西：承诺、兴奋、慷慨、爱。当我们的自我意识或自尊已经被之前让我们感到非常不配或不讨人喜欢的遭遇所削弱时，这就更难了。这个人，你知道，当他们出现并且拥有所有这些
grand gestures, they can seem like our white night. But here are a series of very important questions to help you discern whether that is love or love bumming. How does the pace of the relationship make you feel? And where do you feel these feelings? In your stomach, in your heart, in your body. is there a difference between what you're feeling and a similar feeling of anxiety? Are you feeling stable and sure and confident or excited and bubbly and perhaps anxious? If you went away for a month and came back, would the relationship change? Would you be worried about the passion fading? What do you have in common?
宏大的姿态时，他们看起来就像我们的白马王子。但这里有一系列非常重要的问题，可以帮助你辨认那是真爱还是爱的轰炸：关系的节奏让你感觉如何？你是在哪里感受到这些感觉的？在你的胃里，在你的心中，在你的身体里？你所感受到的与类似的焦虑感之间有什么区别？你是感到稳定、确信和自信，还是兴奋、冒泡、也许还有焦虑？如果你离开一个月再回来，这种关系会改变吗？你会担心激情消退吗？你们有什么共同点？
Do you have shared interests? Do you have shared values? is there a genuine foundation to your relationship? Does it feel like there won't be a future if the future doesn't happen now? If you slowed everything down, would they still be there? And finally, is your life still yours or is your life your relationship? Is your relationship and your attachment to this person taking over? These questions are important because they give us a chance to,
你们有共同的兴趣吗？你们有共同的价值观吗？你们的关系有真正的基础吗？如果未来不现在发生，是不是就感觉不会有未来了？如果你把一切都慢下来，他们还会陪着你吗？最后，你的生活依然是你的生活，还是你的生活就是你们的关系？这段关系以及你对这个人的依附是不是正在接管一切？这些问题很重要，因为它们给了我们一个机会去，
pause and really assess, you know, what we are experiencing based on what we have established are the distinctions between love and love bombing. It kind of gives us a bit of a brief time out to switch on that critical thinking and logical part of our brain and just explore whether this is all too good to be true or made to last. If it all keeps coming back to that one explanation only, this is love bombing, there are a few things that we can do. First thing, I get wanting to just like wait it out and see if things change because it's really hard to not want to bathe in that glow of feeling really wanted and feeling really loved. But I want you to remember the more time you stay is time that you will continue to feel
停下来，根据我们已经确定的爱与爱的轰炸之间的区别，真正评估我们正在经历的事情。它有点像给我们提供了一个短暂的暂停时间，来开启我们大脑中批判性思维和理智的部分，并探索这一切究竟是好得不真实还是能够持久。如果一切最终都回到那唯一的一个解释：这就是爱的轰炸，我们可以做几件事。第一件事，我理解只想顺其自然、看看事情会不会改变的心情，因为很难不去沐浴在那种渴望被需要、渴望被爱的光芒中。但我希望你记住，你停留的越多，你就会继续感受到
connected to this person. The feel good feelings are kind of the poison. They are the weapon in the situation. They are a manipulation strategy. And it's the thing that will keep you attached. even if you think that you can keep some emotional distance, sometimes we just don't have as much control as we think. And so the best thing to do is to kind of,
与这个人的联系。这种感觉良好的感觉有点像毒药。它们是这种情况下的武器。它们是一种操纵策略。正是这种东西会让你依附于对方，即使你认为自己可以保持一些情感距离，有时我们的控制力就是没有我们想象的那么强。所以最好做的事情是，
firstly, pull back and check their reaction and practice setting some boundaries. You know, just say to them, I'm sorry I can't see you this weekend. Please don't send me gifts at work. Please don't show up and announced. Set a boundary and see how they respond. if they get incredibly aggressive or defensive or upset,
首先，退后一步，观察他们的反应，并练习设定一些界限。你知道，直接对他们说：对不起，我这周末不能见你。请不要把礼物寄到我的公司。请不要突然造访。设定一个界限，看看他们的反应。如果他们变得极其好斗、防备或者沮丧，
I think that's a pretty clear sign that what's happening right here is something that is going to eventually turn into something much worse. If you find that this person is not responsive or respectful of your boundaries, get out. Get out of that situation. Remember those three phases that we spoke about before? Yeah, I think the second and the third stage is really where once they have their claws in you, they know. They know what they have. And it becomes really hard for you to leave. Psychologically, emotionally, socially, physically, it becomes so much harder because they do have the control.
我认为这是一个非常明显的信号，表明这里发生的事情最终会演变成更糟糕的事情。如果你发现这个人对你的界限没有反应或不尊重，那就离开。离开这种状况。还记得我们之前讨论过的那三个阶段吗？是的，我认为第二阶段和第三阶段才是真正当他们把爪子伸向你时，他们就清楚了。他们清楚自己拥有什么。而你想离开就会变得非常困难。在心理上、情感上、社会上、身体上，这变得难得多，因为他们确实掌控着主动权。
So I do just really want to remind you, firstly, it's not your fault if that is something that you are going through right now. It is only natural that you felt really compelled and attracted to this person. But please don't confuse chemistry with compatibility. Chemistry will have you feeling amazing, but it's short-lived. Compatibility is a slow burn. It is an alignment. It is a bond that grows over time. It has shared values.
所以我真的很想提醒你，首先，如果你现在正经历这一切，这不是你的错。你对这个人感到强烈的吸引和着迷，这是再自然不过的事了。但请不要把化学反应和契合度混为一谈。化学反应会让你感觉棒极了，但它很短暂。契合度是慢热的。它是一种契合。它是一种随着时间推移而增长的纽带。它有共同的价值观。
It has shared experiences. And it's real. And love bombing is artificial. So just a reminder that what feels good now is not going to feel as amazing in three months or six months. And you could have had that time to really resettle into yourself and find somebody who, yeah, we'll do all the really nice things that will also be committed to staying and staying because they love you and care about you, not because they want to control you. So I hope that you have at least learned something from this episode.
它有共同的经历。它是真实的。而爱的轰炸是虚假的。所以只是提醒一下，现在感觉良好的事情，在三个月或六个月后就不会感觉那么美妙了。你本可以利用这段时间重新找回自我，找到一个确实会做所有非常美好事情的人，同时他也致力于留下来，留下来是因为他们爱你并关心你，而不是因为他们想控制你。所以我希望你至少从这一集中学到了一些东西，
you've taken something away. Thank you for listening. Thank you for coming along for the journey. If there is somebody in your life who you think might benefit from hearing this episode, please feel free to share it with them. It also allows us to reach new ears, reach new people. Make sure that you are following along.
你有所收获。谢谢你的收听。谢谢你陪伴这段旅程。如果你的生活中有人可能会从中受益，请随时与他们分享。这也让我们能够接触到新的听众，接触到新的人。确保你一直在关注我们。
And if you want to, it only takes a couple of seconds to leave us five stars. It really makes my day. If you want to leave a review as well, I read them all and they are quite special to me. So thank you so much for, yeah, considering it. I would love to hear from you as well. If you have anything else you want to contribute to this episode,
如果你愿意的话，只需花几秒钟给我们留下五星好评。这真的会让我的一天都变得美好。如果你也想留下一条评论，我都会阅读，它们对我来说非常特别。所以非常感谢你，是的，考虑这样做。我也很想听到你的声音。如果你有什么想为这一集贡献的内容，
if you have an episode suggestion, we are always open to hearing feedback to hearing ideas, topics that you want us to explore. So make sure that you are following me at that psychology podcast or you want to see behind the scenes. You can follow me at Gemma Spagg. And until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. and we will talk soon.
如果你有节目的建议，我们总是乐意听取反馈、听取想法、了解你希望我们探讨的主题。所以请确保你在That Psychology Podcast关注我，或者你想看幕后花絮。你可以关注我Gemma Spagg。直到下次，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一些，我们很快会再聊。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
2%。这是在也有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健康和抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会从另一端走出来，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即TWO%在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends.
当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。
Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. I got you. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J.
相信我，宝贝。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。我支持你。在The Look Back at it播客中。从1979年开始，对我和说那是个重大时刻。84年对我很重要。我是山姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的人以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at It。嘿，你们好吗？你们正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《用最难的方式学习》。这个空间关乎黑男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方说真的都不安全，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号，你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《用最难的方式学习》。在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷g·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的天呐，太震惊了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困于爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困于爱》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。真人保证。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。